hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in the
dialogue the fado there's a brief
discussion of
two of the virtues actually in
conjunction
with two of the other virtues
and socrates is going to distinguish
between our ordinary way of looking at
courage and temperance and the
philosophical way of doing so he'll
actually go
so far as to say that it's only the
philosophers
who genuinely are courageous or
temperate and we'll see why in just a
moment
before that though let's think about
what it means
in very broad senses to talk about a
person
as having courage or exhibiting courage
and having temperance or moderation is
often how we would put it to control
self-control um
what do we mean when we say those terms
often we'll talk about courage
as involving doing something even though
you're afraid we you know we've got
these truisms
the courageous person the brave person
it's not that they're
not afraid at all it's that they
overcome their fear
these are the sorts of things that we
say in our culture and that's what they
said in greek culture
around the time of plato as well so it
involves acting
and the action could be standing fast
you know not necessarily going somewhere
and doing something but
staying where you are acting despite
one's fears
going out and and doing something
in the face of that which could be
terrifying
that which could be worrisome
um courage could involve the battlefield
it could involve
going to talk to some girl you know when
you're feeling kind of shy i remember
when i was in uh in ninth grade
entering high school it was a big thing
to call a girl on the phone
and and i think for many people nowadays
that wouldn't be anything at all but
then you know by the time that i was
a junior i was an old hand at this sort
of thing
but there were other things that i was
afraid of as well and it
it took doing you know things to
overcome
that that trepidation that i had um
so courage we've got a ordinary common
sense notion of it's not the same thing
as like not having any fear
always you know jumping into danger
that's that's a little bit too far
but it's not cowardice cowardice is when
you you don't stand up to fears and you
let your fears master you and dominate
you
what about temperance so far in greek
which we can translate as moderation or
self-control
it's understood as being control over
one's
desires for physical pleasures so for
eating
for drinking for intoxication for
comfort for sex these are the sorts of
things that that comprise
temperance i think that we could you
know in plato's world
we could probably if we were to bring
him up to date we could probably say you
know watching tv all day
that would be an example of intemperance
or a lack of self-control
that could that could fit in there as
well you know loving spectacles loving
things for the eyes so we have a
a commonsensical understanding of these
and notice that i put
that these involve not just a
pattern of action if we say that
somebody's courageous we can count on
them to act in a certain way
consistently there's a pattern to their
their behavior there's a
there's a structure there's a kind of
schema there of how they're going to
react
it also involves having the right kind
of desires or
or desi desire or desires i put here
but it also involves at least for plato
some kind of knowledge or reasoning
process
now that's an addition on plato's part
that isn't necessarily there in other
people's conception of virtue
but that's going to be very important
for plato as we're going to see
so if we think about it in terms of a
reasoning process we can
ask why is a person
courageous or why is a person tempered
what is the structure of their
motivation and that's a matter partly of
desires that's a matter
partly of of reasoning so the affective
and the cognitive
come together in that respect
now why are most people courageous
what is it that they want what's the
thing that they are
actually trying to to to attain or to
avoid
what's at risk what's at play what's the
value
that's at stake in acting courageously
well if somebody
behaves courageously on the battlefield
if they think that death is a bad thing
and most people do think that death is a
bad thing
why are they risking death
you know we could come up with a couple
candidates could be to
you know protect others
i'm gonna go to war because my homeland
is being threatened i don't want my wife
and children to be at risk of
you know ancient greek warfare is pretty
brutal
sometimes conquered cities the wife
would become a slave
little babies would be killed read the
iliad you know
children become slaves as well who knows
what would happen to them so you know
there's there's the
need to protect others we could say the
same thing about those who
engage in in protection uh
you know more locally against criminals
against
fire against you know disasters
but what else why why else is a person
risking
um their life
well it could be in order to
get something out of it a thief can be
kind of courageous
they're daring why because they want to
they want to make some money
they want to get some resources it could
be you know pursuing physical pleasure
as well
um the one that plato focuses on the
most
fear of dishonor you know this is not
athens but the same sort of mentality
was was
quite prevalent in athens um a spartan
mother
told her son come home with your shield
or on your shield meaning being born
dead
on your shield uh as sort of the
stretcher that they would carry you
along with don't throw away your shield
which is what you would do if you had to
run away right because you have this big
heavy thing that's weighing you down
come home with your shield because you
stood fast and fought at the battle
or on your shield dead as somebody who
wasn't dishonored
now plato says
this is not really genuine courage
as a matter of fact it's courage in a
way
but it's also cowardice in a way so
courage
the way that most people have it the way
that most people exhibit it when they do
have it or exhibit it
is really a mixture of itself and its
opposite
courage and cowardice now how can that
be
well they stand up against fear
because they have other fears that
they're
more concerned with and he doesn't worry
so much about protecting others that
could be an interesting counter example
to this
but he says if you're afraid of being
dishonored if you're afraid of what
other people are going to say
so you're out there even though you're
scared of dying
the philosopher actually isn't afraid of
dying because he understands death is
not a bad thing
but if you're like an ordinary person
you're out there afraid of dying
afraid of the pain that's going to
happen when somebody shoves a spear
through you or
hacks you with an axe and leaves you for
dead as you bleed out
and you're willing to take that risk
because you're
even more afraid of what they're going
to say
if you come home without your shield
you're a coward
you're just a courageous coward you're a
mix
an interesting mix the philosopher he
says
is going to exhibit courage but not
because he's worried about
you know gain or honor or those sorts of
things
what about temperance self-control
you know it's probably a good thing if
we don't eat more than we
ought to or we don't you know seek out
super rich foods
we live in an environment today where um
there's all sorts of dangers lurking and
that's why we're
so many of us are obese you know in
western society
and it's actually starting to hit the
third world as the third world becomes
more prosperous many of them become
obese
because the food stuffs that we have are
super tasty
super abundant calorie rich fat rich
even though the the fat free things are
probably not particularly good for you
because they
bring about you know other issues as
well
temperance would mean not going to the
buffet
because what happens when you go to the
buffet well you want to eat more
right it would also mean um
saying no to seconds it would mean
keeping portion size to a reasonable
amount
it would mean probably eating tasty food
but not going nuts about it where you
need to squander a lot of money
on exotic ingredients or you know the
absolutely freshest things flown in from
peru
we could say the same thing for all
sorts of other bodily pleasures as well
you know do you need i don't know how
how high
uh thread count can go but let's say
that i don't maybe there's a thousand
thread count sheets do you really need
that
or is the the cheap sheets pretty much
about the same
level i i've actually you know i
remember the first time i actually slept
on good sheets
first time in my life because so i you
know it was staying with somebody who
cared about that sort of thing
and it did feel nice there was a
difference
but that's not the sort of difference
that your your life should revolve
around
you got to keep these things in check
you got to keep in moderation
uh the ancient greeks thought nothing
too much
um what else sex we can talk about that
we can talk about um taking you know
intoxicants
you shouldn't drink too much alcohol
shouldn't drink too much coffee if
you're a coffee addict like i am
i'm actually in the process of cutting
back from two pots a day
to one pot a day that's rough going
because i'm not particularly temperate
now here's where it gets really
interesting why do people exhibit
temperance
what's the reason what is it that
they're trying to get out of that
is it that they do it because that's the
thing to do and it's just a good thing
in
and of itself that's not the reason why
most people are
temperate or moderate it's so that they
can enjoy
other
pleasures so you know
i should uh subject my body to exercise
and you know pay attention to my diet
so i can be healthy so i can live longer
and enjoy more pleasures
or i should do that you know i should
work out here's a great example
when i was uh in my senior year of high
school
and then for a little bit after that i
used to do some pretty extensive
endurance
you know lifting workouts and i would do
that for
anywhere from like you know two to three
hours a day most days
and i would go to the y because the y
was where the serious lifters went
i knew guys who would go to the y they
would do their real workout
and then they would go to one of the
other health clubs that back then it was
victani was the big one
and what would they do there pick up
women
um they wouldn't actually do a real work
out there they'd like pretend to work
out
why were they doing all of this you know
painful activity
so they could you know get dates
so they could so they could enjoy other
pleasures
intimacy you know sex all those sorts of
things
so socrates is saying that
if you're giving up pleasures if you're
being moderate just so that you can
enjoy other pleasures
similarly with courage there's actually
some intemperance there's a lack of
self-control to your self-control
it's not pure it's mixed
it's being done for the sake of its
opposite
only the philosopher is truly temperate
now i'm going to erase some of this
stuff here
and put in socrates at his own answer
about this he says what actually calls
the shots in these cases
wisdom now wisdom is another one of
the virtues for socrates and so you have
one virtue
that sort of is the archetectonic virtue
for the others
he says that when it comes down to it
here we go there's only one currency for
which
all these tokens of ours should be in
exchanged and that is wisdom in fact
it's wisdom that makes
possible courage and self-control
and it goes on further and says and it
also makes justice
or in a word true goodness and the
presence or absence of pleasures
or fears or other such feelings makes no
difference at all
whereas morality that's based on
emotional values
is a mere illusion a thoroughly
common conception which has nothing
sounded and nothing true
the true moral ideal whether
self-control
or justice or courage the real thing
is a sort of purification
a purgation from these emotions wisdom
is itself
a purification that's that's required
for that so
what does wisdom consist in being
freed
from concern
with pleasures
pains
emotions in general
and desiring the good solely for the
sake of the good
a different kind of desire desiring to
be a
courageous person that is a person whose
response to danger and to fearful things
is actually guided by wisdom guided by
knowledge of what truly is fearful and
what
isn't really fearful what the point of
genuine
action and courage is likewise for
temperance
temperance is really governed by
for the philosopher wisdom otherwise
it's really
in temperance disguised as temperance
and you may in fact be able to develop a
habit
of resisting alcohol or cigarettes or
sex
but you're doing it just for the sake of
something else with respect to which
you're not self-controlled with respect
to which
you're intemperate so this is what
socrates says wisdom
courage and temperance really are
in themselves the the true forms of them
not the not the stuff that we see in
ourselves not the stuff that the common
conception has
so only the philosopher truly has these
virtues